cleveland browns they were missing no
pieces on sunday night football last
night we were there rodney you picked
the browns
you said to me right before the
commercial break you're like i'm i'm
changing my pick
i'm going with the browns you coming
with me and i was like i got a i got a
record to protect here man i'm on the
heater of life
and i should have done it and i should
have done it because when you watch
baker mayfield play this year
he's one of the hottest quarterbacks in
football right now ben roethlisberger
has been slowing down
this last month of the season losing
games because of it you made the exact
right pick
what made you believe that even with
everything they're missing including
their head coach and offensive line
coach
i just you know in the playoffs it's
about heart it's about
you know um it's just like everything
starts over
and i just believed in cleveland i just
believed in the heart of
jarvis landry i believed in in baker
mayfield i believe in those tough
athletic running backs and i believe in
kevin stefanski out coaching mike tomlin
from his basement something that you
said that mike thomas is going on to the
hall of fame
and kevin stefanski's going to the
basement but man but let me just say
this man
all respect to baker mayfield the
cleveland browns and what kevin
stefanski to me this further cements
his legacy and what he should be and he
should be
the coach of the year i mean i thought
he was outstanding and for him to coach
in the basement
and come out with this type of simple
game plan and absolutely kick
the pittsburgh steelers but i thought it
was outstanding and he definitely
deserves coach of the year because of it
the sun is rising on a new era of
cleveland browns football that was what
was so clear to me watching that game
last night
that they had they're they're down all
these pieces coach callahan one of the
best offensive line coaches and really
baker's success this year has been so
tied to the rebuilding of that offensive
line that that's where he's had all his
success he has time now he feels
protected he's confident in that pocket
last year was terrible you know the
first year they had a great offensive
line
baker was really good second year they
had a bad offensive line baker's really
bad
third year callahan comes over he fixes
this offensive line
stefanski too whoever you want to give
credit to and obviously the players as
well
they dominated the steelers last night
rodney you watch them in that running
game sometimes it was kareem hunt chubb
they were 10
12 yards down the field completely
untouched and baker
when you put prolific passing game with
the prolific running game
and you spot him 28 points you don't
lose those games often i love how the
browns just ran up the score though
when they had the lead they kept that
gas pedal down that's what great teams
do
and anybody who's been watching afc
north football for as long as i have
being a bengals fan being in cincinnati
right now
knows you better keep scoring or big ben
will catch you
and that's how the browns won it i'll
tell you this i was really i have a lot
of respect for mike tomlin
no question about i think he's a great
football coach but he did not have his
team prepared last night
absolutely not mentally physically they
weren't prepared
they didn't play with energy they didn't
play with passion you mean to tell me
uh eight nine time pro bowler the very
first player of the game
and your dad he said it perfectly
he's in a rush to block the the
defensive tackle on the left side
and he he's more concerned about that
than snapping the ball it's the little
things in playoffs and big games like
this and i played in a bunch of them
you need your key players you need your
veteran players
to at least hold down the fort you need
them to be your foundation you need that
stability from
your um from your veteran players and
then juju
why would juju smith schuster say what
he said i mean it was so disrespectful
it was so
unnecessary for him to come out and say
that and why would you want to give
added motivation to a team that has gone
through so much adversity this team is
trying to figure out
what they're doing in terms of their
coaching and their players
but you want to give them added
motivation kind of reminds me of when we
played in the super bowl against the
philadelphia eagles ferdi mitchell was
talking all that trash
and it really took our level of focus
from here on to the next level
and trust me when you when you attack
somebody one person
on a team the entire team's gonna rally
behind it
and i just felt like you know mike
tomlin didn't have this team
ready to go juju smith schuster he was
talking like the pittsburgh steelers
were really that team
that they were you know years ago and
they're just not that team
jack baker mayfield's a guy that has
this just eternal
chip on his shoulder that just lives
there he just wakes up every morning and
he says he's waking up feeling dangerous
i think he's waking up feeling mad
i think he's just constantly thinking
about everybody that said something
negative throughout the course of his
life
of which there are many and for you to
just go ahead and put a little gasoline
on that fire of his
and for them him to them to be able to
hear that and push that out to the rest
of the team
i had a feeling before this game that
the browns were gonna be mad
based on that comment they played mad i
don't think i realized though
how mad they were until the post game
the celebration baker running into the
locker room going the browns is the
browns all of that stuff
they're playing corvette corvette in the
locker room listen to it just going full
troll mode on juju smith shuster this
was a team that was playing like they
had just been insulted
within 48 hours of kickoff and that's
what they did the amazing thing is
you have a guy like chase claypoint i
want to play this for you right now
rodney
chase claypool today the steelers wide
receiver room
doubling down on the trash talk here
this clip from claypool
a day after a brutal loss to the browns
you know bad loss but um
browns are gonna get clap next week so
it's all good
come on chase why would you say that man
just
see that's what i'm talking about man
you know like there's there has to be a
level of class
and and i'm listen coach belichick would
never allow
something like that to happen and you
know in our championship teams and when
you lose you have to be
you have to stay humble and you have to
compliment the other team and i'm just
i'm really disappointed in that they had
an opportunity to win they had two weeks
off basically they
basically um coach gave him off last
week and they played against baker them
you know yesterday i'm just really
disappointed in that comment because
they had they haven't learned anything
they got their butts kicked up and down
that field they are embarrassed on
national television in front of
millions of people and they're still
talking that trash but that's the new
pittsburgh steelers i guess that's the
young players in this league
and i like chase and as bad as it was
in the fourth quarter of that game big
ben comes back throws for 500 yards to
get him back into it throws four
interceptions in the game four
touchdowns too 500 yards that just piled
on in the second half i mean
first half of the season this steelers
team couldn't miss in the second half of
that game they started to remember that
feeling a little bit but it was too far
gone
but it all came down to that fourth down
it was a fourth and one
the steelers offense is rolling it looks
like they have all the momentum behind
them they're going up and down the field
every time that they have it and it's a
fourth and one at about the 50 and even
if it was a three you know a one
possession game
i would have still said steelers got to
go for this they got to go for this
fourth down right here
but in that game there's no choice you
absolutely have to go for that so here
is mike tomlin
explaining why he didn't but the
explanation for me not even close to
suffice hear this
we had had some stops i wanted to pin
them down
and maybe provide the short field for
our offense we had maybe
two or three consecutive stops and so um
i just wanted to keep the momentum going
uh in in terms of field positioning but
we weren't good enough in terms of doing
that
let me tell you this you think about
defensive player defensive coaches
they're a lot more conservative
as far as head coaches as far as going
forward on four from two you look what
mike brabel did
he didn't go forward but a lot if these
were offensive coaches they definitely
go for that and i'm just
once again mike tomlin i just didn't
think he was at his very best yesterday
like fourth down and one
you got all these weapons you know
cleveland's playing soft coverage all
they're basically doing is playing cover
two
they're dropping back they're rushing
four dropping seven and ben
he could just dink and dunk him all the
way down the field i i just did not
believe that mike tomlin would punt that
ball in that situation i look at big ben
moving forward they need to move on from
big ben he's old he's done
and he's costing a whole bunch of money
and i think he's really
he's really got that organization
stagnant where they can't move forward
in this league you have to have an
athletic
quarterback that can move that is smart
they can throw from the pocket
that could move a little bit escape and
i just and ben he looks old like tom
brady is older than ben
but ben looks like an old man he looks
like he should be done playing football
yeah
he can throw but when you get in those
passing lanes when you put a little
pressure on him
he's done and then think about the game
plan think about the game plan
68 passes 500 yards
68 passes they have done a poor job of
supplying
um ben roethlisberger with offensive
linemen so they can run the football
and then they have to they have to do
something at the running back position
james connor stays
hurt you have to upgrade it running back
you need a guy that can stay healthy you
need a guy
that is a lot more talented than james
connor at the running back position
because that's the only way you're going
to get back to being
a legitimate force in the afc you can't
just have a quarterback in the playoff
game throwing the ball 68 times come on
jack that is crazy does that sound crazy
to you
68 times everything you just said i
could not agree with more it's time they
got to go
and if they don't i think they're going
to come into next year it's going to
start to look like brett favre towards
the end of his career where he just does
he's just a step slower
you know he's getting hit more his
passes aren't quite as accurate it's the
game that we saw in the first quarter
last night out of big ben
you're just gonna we've already all year
seen those i think he's probably now
between 15 and 25 in terms of
quarterbacks
around the league and if you if you
continue this the next couple years
very quickly you are going to have the
worst quarterback in the afc north
you might next year i mean assuming joe
burrow comes back healthy
you might end up with the worst
quarterback in the afc north they need a
mac jones they need to go pick somebody
in the draft high
maybe you bring back big ben for a
transitional year if you will
but when you look at his contract and
what he would be due to make if you do
bring him back
it is just it may be a bridge too far
that's some crazy crazy money you're
talking about if you're going to bring
him
back let's get to the ravens keep it in
the decision lamar jackson the story was
he couldn't go win a playoff game and he
did what'd you think of his performance
i thought he was outstanding and you
think about lamar and
the tough part about defending him is
you can hold him down hold him down hold
him down
and then all of a sudden you get a
little relaxed and then boom
48 yard touchdown and that's how he is
he's so explosive
and what i liked about him was even
though he threw that interception
it seemed like he he's starting to grow
with his patience
it's not just hey just throw the ball a
run
he's really trying to survey he's really
trying to go through his reads and he's
just playing loose having fun
and trying to make plays i thought he
was really outstanding but really the
story of the game
was the defense and we'll talk about
that in a few minutes
of course let's hear it from the victor
here's coach harbaugh lamar jackson
after a big win getting that playoff dub
for lamar here they were
man it feels good you know mr jameson um
i knew
you know we had the capability of doing
that uh but
you know there's gonna always be no
naysayers you know no matter what so
he's just one game at a time
i appreciate the um the win hard fought
team victor you know
they played great as well you know
tennessee pretty um played a pretty good
game you know on both sides of the ball
um but i'm grateful for the win this may
be the best one i've ever been
associated with defensive effort like
you said
it was discipline it was eyes on your
luggage it was finishing it was run
to the ball it was tackling up front our
defensive line did a phenomenal job
against their very good offensive line
so we got him we got him stopped a lot
of times before he got started
all those things came into play yeah you
think about this defensive line and the
first time they met brandon williams
wasn't there khalees campbell he wasn't
there
the both the big guys showed up and they
did an outstanding job in the middle
pushing the pocket
but that wasn't the key the key was
those guys
on the end and i'll tell you this mike
vrabo when he gets a chance to watch
that tape he's going to be really proud
in a weird way because mike varible was
one of the most outstanding
defensive ends at setting the edge and
that's what baltimore did they did a
great job of setting the edge
they didn't give derrick henry any any
opportunity really to break through the
middle
and every time that he would come
through the middle they would make his
feet stutter
and i thought this was probably the best
effort that i've seen anybody really
go against um derek henry he it just a
flat out great performance
by this defense and you know they have
the secondary to complement them
and when you get that type of you know
push up front
and that type of energy and emotion that
they play with
it was just really outstanding
it was and and they weren't multiple
they're talking about the titans
a big part of this run that they've put
together under variable is that
tannehill's been much better
and he's been able to go win games when
they do slow down derek henry and
baltimore played him perfectly just like
you're describing
but tana hill wasn't good enough to take
the ball and go build a lead i mean they
had a ten point lead and
our question is where could lamar come
from behind this is the first time we've
seen him
come from behind the way that he did and
it wasn't necessarily all with his arm
you described that
55-yard touchdown run i think coach
harbaugh said it's the best one that
he's ever seen
a quarterback have and i i just started
thinking about you know
when's the last time i've seen a
quarterback or how many quarterbacks in
the last decade
could score a touchdown on that play and
the list may be
lamar jackson i mean unless mike vick
played in the last decade i guess he did
you know
the back half of his career maybe mike
vick and lamar jackson can you think of
anybody else who scores a touchdown on
that play
that's how prolific he is as a runner
maybe maybe maybe patrick mahomes
maybe maybe patrick mahomes but i was
thinking this
i think let me just say this i was
thinking this last weekend
and i i think you'll get get a kick out
of this i was wondering
that effort to get derrick henry 2 000
yards
last week i thought i thought they
shouldn't even go for it i thought they
should just
rest them and you know rest some of the
offensive linemen
and to me it just looked like they were
tired
when you go think about if only eight or
nine guys reach 2 000 yards
man it takes a lot out of you and they
just didn't play with that same
passion they didn't they didn't play
with that same just you know emotion
that's what you need and i think them
pursuing 2 000 yards really affected
their ability
to run the ball yesterday
it's it's an interesting take because
they still were in that tight
competition in the south right with
indy and so they could have wound up
playing the buffalo bills and the
buffalo bills
arguably a tougher match up i guess
we'll see how that plays out
you know bills look damn good yesterday
too but the baltimore ravens can play as
well
but they also maybe could have won the
game without giving him 30 plus carries
because that was the most carries that
he had had
all year talking about derek henry so to
your point
maybe they could have won the game
without going for the 2000 because it
did get clear in the second half of the
game in week 17 that they were chasing
the 2k for him and he'll have the 2k and
forever people will talk about this
season for derrick henry
but they're not going to talk about this
playoff run because this was a pretty
weak performance from the offense and i
agree with you
i thought they looked shot i thought
derek henry looked like he had carried
the ball a million times this year
which he has and that's the reason he
has 2k and it's also the reason the
titans are
out of the playoffs absolutely and and i
look at vrebel
on that fourth was it fourth down and
two it was a fourth down and short and i
just
you got derek henry you have derek henry
you have aj brown you have john lew
smith you have an athletic quarterback
and i was just so stunned that they
didn't go
for it on that fourth and short and i'm
like why is he being so conservative
do we have any do we have any tape on
mike vrabel making a comment on that
okay yeah but i was just really really
right i was just really
really shocked that mike vrabel didn't
go for it on a fourth and two when
you're in the playoffs
yeah i understand trying to be
conservative but at the same time you
got to let your team know that you
believe in them
and that you're going to be aggressive
and that you're going to attack and
that's the way we want our championships
we were aggressive
we were smart and we attacked and we
didn't you know we didn't
you got to be able to make those calls
if you're mike tomlin fourth down in one
you got to go for it if you're mike
vrable you have to go for it especially
when you have derek henry a guy that ran
for 4
2 000 yards and you have an athletic
quarterback that can get the ball down
the field you have to go for it
rodney i'll tell you what on safety
blitz we put together an absolute dream
team on the production side so that when
you just bring up random things like
that and you said i'd like to see that
fourth down clip of raibl
well here it is let's hear from brave
bro in that board okay
just decided to punt i thought we were
playing well defensively thought we
would
get a get a punt inside the 10 and you
know be able to
play the field position game had some
time there that i felt like
yeah we could and you know we
we held him to a field goal it just you
know i mean we were playing against a
a kicker there that you know kicks them
from the 40
you know it's um becomes a field
position battle and i thought that
you know we'd get a stop and pin them
inside the
the ten and you know the way we were
playing defensively i was really proud
of those guys that you know me obviously
lamar had fantastic
day but i thought we were you know
dialed in i thought you know enjoyed
watching those guys play defense
i don't know how to take his body
language but to me it it almost seems
like
that's a situation where he feels like
he almost regrets
that he didn't go for it and um i've
known vrabel and he's a very honest
hard-working smart individual he cares
about his players
and i know he's he's really disappointed
that they didn't win this game
um but in a situation like that and
you're trying to send a message not only
to your team but the other team you have
to go for it mike vrable you have to go
for it you're aggressive player you're a
smart player
you just you got to go for it and you
have to lay all your chips on the table
and see what happens you got derrick
henry you got a lot of talent
and your team they did their thing this
year put put themselves in a position
to have this opportunity and you gotta
you gotta make the most of it you gotta
all chips in rod i'm gonna revert back
to your previous point and we'll move on
he's a defensive coach too that's
another defensive coach that's not going
for it in a fourth down situation so
for whatever it's worth he did rely on
the d there didn't rely on the o however
you want to look at it let's get it to
brady and breeze talking about
offense this will be round three this
game has been
the weakness if there's been a weakness
on this season for tom brady and it's
been phenomenal this year has been
phenomenal
i think he's exceeded every expectation
you could have ever had for him changing
teams
no off-season and what he's put together
from a recruiting standpoint from a
quarterbacking standpoint this is mvp
form this is prime
tom brady he looks unbelievable right
now
but his weakness has been the new
orleans saints why do you think that is
rodney can he right the ship
with how well they've been playing well
it just depends on what that offensive
line does if that offensive line which
had played
really well the back end of the season
if they protect him and give him time
and we talked about this
yeah he's gonna be fine if they give him
time but if cameron jordan and all those
guys they get up in his face
and they start hitting tom you're gonna
start seeing him do the old eli
falling to the ground taking sacks um
you know throwing the ball away
getting frustrated yelling at his
teammates yeah we see the good time
but when tom starts to get hit and tom
starts to take some shots as much as i
love him
dude you can rattle him you got you can
rat him but
you know it's going to come down to the
new orleans saints secondary and you
know how disciplined they're out
they are on the corners and if they give
up big plays but
i think it's going to be a great game
and and drew brees told me he says
anytime that i play against tom there's
more of a sense of urgency
when we have the ball because tom is on
the other side so he has a lot of
respect when when drew told me that this
summer
he has a lot of respect for tom but he
feels like
his team is in a good situation
yeah i think the bucks have been
trending upward
faster the last month of the season than
the saints have i have more belief in
where they are right now
now this defense has been a tough
matchup for gronk and for the receivers
of the bucks i just doubt that it plays
out the same way that i mean there's
been blowouts
new orleans against tampa they've just
been blowouts but with how
abs been playing i just went back and
just i've just been watching nothing but
just antonio brown iso film
he has been open i mean open for weeks
now weeks and weeks and weeks and i know
he's had explosive games where he's
going 100 plus yards multiple touchdowns
but they could be 200-yard games i mean
he's running wide open
and all of a sudden now you're seeing
tom brady trust him and look for him and
believe in him yeah but he
he made him earn that you know he made
him slowly earn that back
i i do want to hit this rodney because i
know you've got no jacks don't leave no
no no no jack yeah jack don't leave me
you're my favorite thing
okay go ahead i knew i knew i got you
going there i should have ditched it
right to you go
no no because you were spot on with a b
and a b
to me is their most dangerous weapon
it's it's amazing that you said that
because i'm sitting here and
you know when you watch him on tape it's
like last week i said man he looks so
much faster he looks like his old self
he looks quick he looks fast
he looks energetic he's you know
anything that touches his hands
he's going to catch and they're getting
him the ball he's their most dangerous
weapon
and the funny thing about it is the more
you give him the ball
the better he is so i'm just really
pumped up for antonio brown he's been a
good citizen and even think about this
with brady
he has so much he's trying to implement
the new system
he's trying to let them know what he
wants to run he's trying to form a bond
with all his new teammates
and he's trying to keep antonio brown on
a straight and narrow
and you wonder why the patriots have had
success and why i have two super bowl
rings because i have a leader i have a i
had a quarterback
that is so caring and a guy that you
know he cares so much about his team
it's about the team it's never about tom
brady it's never been about tom brady i
remember
one year he bought all the offensive
linemen audis
yeah cars audis and it was like dude
this dude
you know it's like it's it's like tom is
the perfect
leader he is the perfect leader because
he spends time with you
he sits with his teammates he tries to
get to know you he'll pick up the phone
he'll call you he'll text you
and it's to me it's the way he takes
care of his body it's just no surprise
that
i mean he could continue to throw the
ball down the field i just i'm just
thoroughly impressed with a 43 year old
guy is doing in the national football
league
it's remarkable and it's like you said
tampa is a different team
than what the new orleans saints played
before this is a very good team
and they're building confidence they're
flying around and they're starting to
really believe in one another and you
look at ronald jones and leonard
fournette
they're gonna run that ball too so watch
out for tampa bay
what a great pickup for networks what
did what did just an
awesome pickup recruiting job by brady
to go get fournette
he reminds me of like the legarrette
blunt of this team if i can make that
comparison
he's perfect for this playoff stretch
when it gets into january football if
they're going to be on the road maybe
bad weather
if they can get past the saints blunt is
just going to play or
not blunt might as well be blunt you
know yeah
so tough he brings that physical element
you know he brings that physical element
to this team and
i think brady loves that and he also
loves to have multiple backs in the
backfield but just think about
we talk about the trajectory that
tampa's been on the idea that mike
evans and chris godwin can be two and
three wide receivers that they could be
wide receiver two and three
on an offense that also has gronk and
scottie miller ronald jones i mean this
is it's an all-star team
brady left a rebuild in new england for
an all-star team in tampa you got to
give it up for this man and what he's
been doing i wanted to ask you and i
probably blew through our time now but
what the heck i'm still going to do it
heineke taylor heineke comes in for alex
smith he has no business playing the way
he did what'd you think of his
performance
i thought it was i thought it was um
i was just really proud of him i mean he
was he was just tough
you talk about a guy mentally and
physically tough he was beat up
physically but he just kept getting up
and that comes from heart that comes
from the mental
and his teammates the nation i mean
people that aren't even watching in the
football team
um you know fans they was cheering for
this guy
i wouldn't i wouldn't right away name
him the startup but
he would definitely i'm gonna definitely
go out and draft me a quarterback but he
would definitely be in the competition
and i don't know if he's a free agent or
not or what's to deal with his contract
situation but i think that young man
earned him
a few million dollars as a backup
quarterback at this point
so let's let's go to the buffalo bills
this josh allen performance i mean the
way that he's been playing i don't want
to make it just about his playoff
performance because he was off the
charts but he has been this
continuously down the stretch of the
season when you saw it in the playoffs
are you starting to believe this is one
of the real top shelf guys playing the
quarterback position in the league what
were you thinking watching that game
yesterday
well it didn't have it didn't take for
them to get to the playoffs for me to
start believing in josh allen you see
the body of his work throughout the
season and and
really the probably the biggest growth
that i've seen is his patience
and you know before it was everything
had to be down the field
i'm gonna force the ball down the field
now he's okay with a four or five yard
check down
and that's that's growth as a
quarterback because you don't always
feel like you have to have the big play
and he's done such a wonderful job
of just getting everyone involved and
you know what i like about their team is
they play with so much enthusiasm
they they have they have so much love
and respect for one another
and no one cares who gets the credit and
that's a big
that's big props to josh allen because
he's an unselfish guy
any time that somebody's making a
touchdown or somebody creates a turnover
or makes a big play
they're all right there celebrating
embracing one another
and that's one of the biggest things
that we have we always had a close-knit
group that trusted one another
but the quarterback had a big part to do
with that
and josh allen just seems like he brings
everyone together
and i tell you man yeah he's he's an
elite quarterback i mean it's
it's you know if you ask me let me ask
you
who are you taking josh allen or lamar
jackson if you had to choose one
thanks for that question josh allen
that's honestly who i'd take
that's honestly who i would take and and
the reason is because i just don't see
other quarterbacks like him i can't
think of a comparison to him
when i did the interview with him a
couple weeks ago to your point about
going from looking deep all the time to
now being willing to take the short easy
stuff and be accurate with him
he took really seriously studying aaron
rodgers
studying tom brady studying drew brees
just to look at how they created those
easy completions and he still has the
deep ball
and maybe one of the more amazing parts
of his game too is when he takes off and
runs he is so fast and athletic and big
six six 240 and then he can throw the
ball on the run
with perfect accuracy and not only
perfect accuracy
on the run he can push it 30 or 40 yards
down the field
on a laser i don't know who else has
that body that athleticism
and the ability to just put the ball
everywhere now that he's adding that
the easy stuff into his game just the
easy wide open completions to it
it's just a complete quarterback in year
three i mean this has happened fast for
him where he was as the gunslinger
throwing the ball out of bounds that's
what he used to be when he came to the
league
yeah and defensively like when you're
trying to defend him
you know that he has an arm where he can
throw the ball 70 yards down the field
so it forces you to play a little softer
because you're afraid but now that he's
a lot more
patient he's dumping it down and those
four and five six yard gains are getting
him
easy second second and shorts and now
they can do whatever they want to do but
let's talk about stefan diggs because i
voted for him first team all pro and
he's been absolutely
outstanding and i think that was the
best move that he made getting out of
minnesota and coming where he had a
quarterback that's athletic a
quarterback
that really engages him and he and he
likes his quarterback and
it's just really great to see the one
thing i am concerned about with buffalo
is their running back position can they
will they be able to run the ball
against baltimore after that
after them stop in tennessee i just
don't believe i think it's gonna be all
josh allen
and and unfortunately i hope he doesn't
revert back to
trying to throw the ball deep and just
you know making sure that he stays
patient so
it's a lot of little story lines that's
going on and um i'm really excited
to be there um this weekend
when you get into big games like this
late in the year though and with josh in
particular with how big his body is and
his frame is
i very rarely see defenders hit him hard
i think it's just he's
like dk metcalf playing the wide
receiver position like derek henry
playing the running back position some
guys are so big and so
physical that you just can't really get
big shots on him so i
i wouldn't hesitate in a game like this
in a playoff stretch get trying to get
to the super bowl
to allow him to run the ball some
designed runs i'm thinking about that
quarterback draw yesterday because when
he gets to the second level
it's like a six six athletic tight end
that you have to somehow
tackle i mean he's he's a problem when
he gets there think about that goal line
play from yesterday rodney
it was like the tim tebow play
everybody's run block and he's running
to the right and it looks like he's
gonna run in for a touchdown
tight end slips into the back of the end
zone he's full run mode
and it just flips it back there for the
touchdown he does so many things in the
red zone to get seven instead of three
and
this team just scores points i mean they
can score with anybody chiefs
tom brady saints you know i really think
they can score with any of the best
offenses in the league
yeah and think about from a defensive
standpoint like you've played
17 18 weeks of football you're tired
and now you have to deal with a guy
that's 20 something years old
that's big that's strong that's hungry
that's an absolute man and a guy that's
a tough guy like
yeah he's a quarterback but he could
also be a left tackle he can also be a
defensive end he can also be a tight end
that's how big and athletic he is
and you talk about who kind of reminds
you of him
maybe justin herbert but not not the
size as far as the arm strength
and you know the accuracy and things
like that but yeah man josh allen is a
real deal and you know i asked myself
the same question
who would i take and i think that would
be easy you know i would take josh allen
no disrespect
um to lamar jackson i think he's really
starting to try to develop in his
own capacity but i need a quarterback
that is very very accurate you don't
have to be the fastest you don't have to
be the most athletic
and i just think that josh allen you
know what he's done and his growth and
maturity
i just think you know his leadership as
well as his physical skills
buffalo is going to be a problem for the
next decade and a half
at least they're going to be a a true
problem because this guy is a tremendous
leader he brings everyone together in
the locker room
and people like him and it's it's hard
to root against them
it is and lamar jackson has gotten a lot
better as a pastor and
it's not taking anything away from lamar
lamar is a better runner than josh allen
i mean
substantially better when lamar runs he
looks like a punt returner i mean he's
he's better than 99.9 of the league
playing any position
as a runner josh allen's not that but as
a passer
it's it's similar in that way josh
allen's a way better passer than lamar
jackson is right now
let me ask you this i don't want to get
too far off topic but i do think it's an
interesting question like where is lamar
on that scale
since you brought him up like where is
he like when you think tua you think
josh allen you think
watson all these young quarterbacks who
can do both mahomes
where is he on that scale of guys i know
he's at the top as a runner where is he
as a passer
i don't even i don't even think it
matters because what matters is
the system that he's in everybody's in
their own particular system he's in a
system
that works for them and so to compare
him
to you know how accurate he is we know
he's not the most accurate pastor and
that's something that he's getting
better at but
i love his leadership i love the heart
that he plays with and in motion
i love um his teammates i love the fact
that they're
now getting marquis brown involved in
the offense a lot more and it's not just
deep shots now they're starting to work
his route tree
now you see him catching 12 yard passes
seven yard passes 23 yard passes
everything doesn't have to be 60 yards
down the field and if they can keep him
involved in the game
and you know just a quick slant let him
use his speed
they're you know it's going to be tough
to stop them with mark andrews
at the tight end position with the run
game and all the different aspects that
you have to deal with
as a defense trying to stop them from
running the football
but yeah it works perfectly for them and
that's why i say it's it's very
difficult to you know
compare lamar to all those other guys
yeah i hear you i the thing is when
they're both on the same field this
weekend
and they're both lighting up the
scoreboard in different ways it's going
to be so fun to just look back and forth
and
at just the future of the game this is
the future of football
we've seen these young quarterbacks come
into the league and be so exciting in
the regular season
but now to see it filter up into the
postseason and they're just knocking off
all these sort of institution
quarterbacks that have been there
forever the guys that
don't move at all they just stand there
and you're seeing these young guys
dominate in the playoffs too is such a
fun thing to see
just super wild card weekend in general
rodney this is the first
super wild card that we've had only one
first round buy at both of the
conferences
what were your impressions overall what
this was football is there's a 48-hour
football feast what'd you think
hail to the nfl this was amazing
this was amazing even for a guy like me
that watches so much tape this was
amazing
and people text me man i can't believe
we got saturday three games sunday this
is something that nfl should seriously
consider
keeping because now you're bringing in
extra fans
all eyes are on the nfl like it should
be i
mean i really thoroughly enjoyed it i
just think that
it it just opens up so many different
opportunities and everybody gets so
pumped up because now you got
two extra teams being represented that
normally wouldn't be represented in the
playoffs
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports